Michel Rivard prend la route sur le
chemin de la nostalgie avec son nouveau
spectacle le tour du bloc on a tous vécu
la même pandémie et veuve je suis un
gars aussi j'ai besoin de ma solitude
mais j'ai pas je suis très grégaire
quand c'est le temps de l'être et je
m'ennuyais de mon flyben et puis de fil
en aiguille le désir de souligner 50 ans
de chansons
[Musique]
cinq décennies de chansons ça se fait en
grand son équipe a donc décidé de mettre
le paquet comme il voulait faire quelque
chose d'assez événementiel j'ai dit ben
moi l'événement ça serait non seulement
de retrouver mes musiciens mais ça
serait de
c'est plutôt que de mettre des gros
écrans puis des décors mettons du monde
sur la scène résultat on est 12
une promenade musicale durant laquelle
Michel Rivard nous présente avec bonheur
c'est plus grand succès sans rien
occulter
[Musique]
Michel est-ce que je peux vous demander
de nous interpréter deux chansons qui se
retrouvent dans le spectacle parfait
parfait alors donc j'ai écrit dans le
spectacle il y a une seule nouvelle
chanson
que j'avais besoin de faire je me
sentais le besoin d'avoir une chanson au
thème d'avoir une chanson qui ouvre le
spectacle et qui et qui décrit un peu
ce que c'est d'où ça part l'idée du Tour
du bloc que tu sais mais d'une manière
poétique c'est ce que j'ai essayé de
faire que je t'en fais un petit bout
[Musique]
dans l'ancien temps de tes amours la
plus vieille chanson que j'accepte donc
la celle que je considère comme ma
première chanson réussie il y en a eu
d'autres avant que je ne te chanterai
pas
[Rires]
mais la première
la première qui
a été reprise avec vos dommages mais on
l'a même pas mis sur le premier disque
qu'on l'a mis sur le deuxième mais elle
existait bien avant beau dommage cela
s'appelle motel mon repos
[Musique]
je peux rêver je suis avec toi dans un
hôtel
prends ma main le spectacle est Michel
Rivard le tour du bloc est présenté en
fin de semaine au théâtre maison neuve
de la Place des Arts et partira ensuite
en tournée à travers le Québec ici Nabil
Alexandre Chartier Radio-Canada Montréal
et puis le ciel
la pluie
tombe tranquille
sur la sfal de noir
jusqu'à ce